SPEAKER_00: Then the judgment becomes a scheduled decision.
SPEAKER_00: The language changes again.
SPEAKER_00: It is no longer mainly about erosion depth or sealing time.
SPEAKER_00: It is about whether there is enough cause to delay.
SPEAKER_00: Delay has a phone tree.
SPEAKER_00: Delay has cost.
SPEAKER_00: Delay has a visible owner.
SPEAKER_00: If the flight succeeds, the decision becomes precedent.
SPEAKER_00: We flew with that condition and came back.
SPEAKER_00: That fact starts to compete with the warning that preceded it.
SPEAKER_00: This route ran more than once before Challenger.
SPEAKER_00: Each pass made the next one easier to defend.
SPEAKER_00: Engineers were not simply ignored, they were often heard, then absorbed into a process that had learned how to carry their concern without stopping.
SPEAKER_00: Months before Challenger, Roger Boyzoli warned that a similar field joint problem could lead to catastrophe of the highest order and loss of human life.
SPEAKER_00: That memo did not come from hindsight.
SPEAKER_00: It came from inside the system, before the accident, from an engineer close to the hardware.
SPEAKER_00: The temperature pattern also had more weight than the launch night argument made it feel.
SPEAKER_00: When the full flight history was framed one way, the cold weather signal could look debatable.
SPEAKER_00: When the full record was framed another way, cold O-ring distress became much harder to dismiss.
SPEAKER_00: A chart can contain real information and still weaken the warning if it frames the wrong question.
SPEAKER_00: Richard Feynman's later appendix named the broader danger plainly.
SPEAKER_00: Previous success can become misleading evidence.
SPEAKER_00: A survived flight can show that the vehicle got through.
SPEAKER_00: It does not prove the risk was safe to repeat.
SPEAKER_00: By January 1986, Challenger was not facing a new problem.
SPEAKER_00: The program had evidence of o-ring distress.
SPEAKER_00: It had temperature concern.
SPEAKER_00: It had waivers.
SPEAKER_00: It had memos.
SPEAKER_00: It had a known field joint problem.
SPEAKER_00: It had a launch system that kept treating survival as part of the safety case.
SPEAKER_00: Then the weather turned that old problem into a launch decision, January 27, 1986, less than 24 hours before the scheduled launch.
SPEAKER_00: A teleconference connected NASA's Marshall Space Flight Center, Kennedy Space Center, and Morton Thyacol, the contractor that built the solid rocket boosters.
SPEAKER_00: The subject was temperature.
SPEAKER_00: Forecasts and engineering estimates pointed to launch conditions far colder than prior shuttle experience.
SPEAKER_00: The launch temperature would be about 36 degrees Fahrenheit.
SPEAKER_00: The right aft field joint was estimated colder, around 28 degrees Fahrenheit, plus or minus 5 degrees.